So,
there
is
a kind of wisdom that fathers have. And then there's the kind of wisdom my father has.
Um, for example, when he does things, he thinks he's totally brilliant and I just think
he's crazy, you know. For example, when we first immigrated from Hong Kong,
he thought would be a good idea for all of us to have American names which would, you know, make sense because it would
make the transition a lot easier. And so my dad chose the American name
"Ming" even though, it's like not even his Chinese name. It's just like,
another Chinese name, it's like a dynasty. You know. So, um,
so when, um, we came over to this country we really had nothing. We were
penniless. So in order to save money, my dad thought was a really smart
idea to make and design my first winter coat. I was three years
old, and to this day he thinks it's like the best
design. There you go.
Seriously he thinks it's like, "Oh, this is great we should market this."
That's the wisdom that my father has. One more example of his wisdom. One day he came
home and there was a sale on belts, and he was just like bought a
monogramed belt and he was so excited. He's like, "Look at this!" It had
this big shiny letter "A" on it. Even though our family name is Lee. And I was like,
"Dad why did you get a letter A belt that doesn't make any sense." He's like, "Oh I got a letter A because A
is for
ace." Which is. You know like you have to understand something about Chinese people
Like, Chinese people are obsessed about being number one.
Like, you know. You know, like, "I have a belt now it says so, I'm number one - ace." You know.
And that's something, like, if you never noticed in Chinatowns across the country like, Chinese business people, like, they
always have to find
find you know the best number one name for their business in order to bring in all the money and the good fortune.
which is why everything's like an imperial dynasty lucky dragon number one kitchen. Like that's the whole
mentality. That is my dad. That's his mentality.
So, in the first few years of being in this country you know, he had
no time off and worked like crazy and managed to save up a little money to start up his own
business. It was a very modest grocery store in Boston's Chinatown.
And of course he called it Ming's Market. But in Chinese the name of it was pìhng ga síh cheùhng,
which literally means, "Cheap Price Market."
And, and it was that, even as a little kid like, I didn't
understand. Like literally he told me one day that he would like mark up something by 5
cents. You know, like mark up another thing by 10 cents. Like, how are you ever going to make money like
this? This business model is insane.
What's the wisdom of that? You know. But you know, strangely enough almost immediately
he developed a really loyal following in Boston's Chinatown. Because for the first time
I think working families and working poor families actually had a place where they could buy affordable,
healthy, good groceries and eat well. Which is, you know, no small thing when you're poor.
So my dad, after about ten years of having this grocery store, he built it up
to be a very successful business, and by 1989 he had moved into an enormous space that
became New England's largest Asian
market. And at the same time that year, I mean you know I was a snotty teenager.
I still thought, "Well, you're crazy. You're a successful businessman, but you're nuts, you know, crazy ideas." And, you know,
at the same time there is this, he's been running a first floor in this vacant building that
been vacant for like 20, no, 30
years. And the landlord was trying to renovate the other floors to try
to rent it out as retail space. But he was doing everything on the cheap, so
instead of hiring a contractor he was like, welding and renovating on his own without pulling permits.
So, one day as you can probably expect, something got out of hand and this big fire broke out as he was welding.
But it was OK. You know they got all the, they evacuated the building about 150
people. And the fire trucks arrived immediately and everything was fine, until the fire
department hooked up their hoses to the hydrants. And there was no water to fight the fire. And they're like,
"Huh, that's weird." You know. So they went down a couple of
blocks and tried the next hydrant. And it was totally dry. What had happened was
that the city of Boston, a few months prior, they were doing road construction and generally when
you drill, if they drill deep they turn off the water pressure, in case they hit a water main.
And when they sealed up the road they forgot to turn the pressure back up. So the firefighters had no tools to fight
the fire. It was just a disaster. I mean, it was just like an hour later, the building was still on fire
and there's no water there trying to jerry
rig something from a nearby hydrant like, you know, ten blocks
away. And if things couldn't get worse the fire jumped an alley
and the building next door caught on fire. And on the top floor was 10,000 square feet
of illegally stashed fireworks.
So, you know, and so firefighters couldn't scale the ladders on that so there's like. I mean it was a surreal
moment 'cause things are exploding, you know, in celebration, you know. Normally you'd have fireworks
as my dad stood there and completely helpless watching his life's work just
be destroyed in a moment through no fault of his own.
So I got a call. I was a sophomore at the time in college and I went out to the store the next day when
it was, you know, kind of just like smoldering wasn't on fire anymore and as I made my
approach to the store, I remember seeing like three elderly women across the street, and they were crying. And so I
went up to them and I
said, you know, "Is everything OK? Why are you crying?" And lady looked at me. And
then she looked at my dad's store, burned-down store. And pointed and
teary eyed said, you know, "Where are we going to go now that we don't have a home?"
And that was kind of like a turning point for me. I hadn't really thought about my dad's
store in that way, like you know, I thought it was something he was doing to provide for the family. But
in fact he was kind of providing for a Greater Community. He like you
know. These elderly women - they didn't have a community center to go to, They didn't have a public park
in Chinatown, and this was the only place where they would actually run into their friends and they spent a lot of time there.
In a way it was like a second
home. And I guess it is true, it sounds corny, but like you only really
do realize what you have when you lose it. And so. In the months that followed I kept
begging my dad for more stories. You know. And like one time he told me a story about how
a little boy. I asked him–if people–what he did with people who were shoplifters, you know. Because I was really curious and
he said, "Well, you know, one
day, I caught a kid shoplifting. He was only ten, and
he didn't know who I was. I was kind of following him around. He was just like taking stuff, like, stuffing in his bag,
putting in his pockets.
And at one moment he actually took a break from stealing and sat down
and started eating the food he had stolen. He was just right in the middle of an aisle." And my dad came up to him,
he didn't know who he was. He said, "Hey, little boy, have you had enough to
eat?" And little boy rubbed his belly like, "Almost." You know.
My dad's like, "Hey, so where are your parents?" He's like, "Well, they're at work." He's like, "Oh,
"Oh, why aren't you at home?" He's like, "Because there's no food at home."
And my dad said, "Well, you know, when you take stuff, specially if it's at a store, and you don't
pay for it. It's actually stealing."
And the little boy starts getting really nervous like, "Oh my God. This guy's going to get me in trouble."
You know, and he's kind of angling for a way to get out. And my dad's like, "You know, so in the future, if you don't have
anything to eat at home, would you just please just come and find me and ask me for whatever you need?"
" Like if you ask, I'll give you whatever you want. Just don't steal. Because stealing is wrong."
And in the months that followed, I think my dad really
looked forward to seeing the little boy. And it was these stories I was craving and I was asking
my dad because in some way I think I was trying to recreate something that I had lost or had kind of
you know, taken for granted.
So whenever we went to Chinatown, I remember lots of people would come up to us and say, "Please we need a store like
this again. When are you going to open up your store?" And it was hard because my dad was basically kind of penniless.
Like, the fire had
caused about 20 million dollars worth of damage. And he barely had enough insurance to cover it. I mean it was like
not just inventory,  but like, the bean sprout machine, like the machine that he leased to wash
and dry beans for. I mean stuff like
that. And he had no money, but he had this idea that maybe he could pull together what little money he did have
with a lot of the original employees. People for whom they were, they were immigrants and they got their
first jobs through my dad at the
store and had been working there since the 70s. So they pulled together. It was a big risk. The only location
they could find was just on the outskirts of Chinatown, which in the early 90s, during the last recession,
it was like a no man's land. It's like this area. Really like. It was so unsafe, and the only reason you would ever
go there is to like get a prostitute or drugs. You know. It's like. It was so unsafe. At the time
I remember in college thinking like what's the wisdom of that? Like why are you going there? It's so unsafe. No one's
gonna go. It's just gonna, you know, gonna lose your life savings.
But he did it anyways, because he's crazy. You know. And he, um, almost kind of overnight
the place was revitalised, you know. There were really loyal people that, families from the
suburbs came, and gave patronage to my dad, you know. People walked from Chinatown, and then soon
thereafter more and more businesses started popping
up. And then there was more and more foot traffic, and then, then families started moving back into the neighborhood,
and it was amazing thing, like he kind of helped revitalize this neighborhood to the point that
then fifteen years later. It became one of the most valuable pieces of real estate in Boston. Which is why
My dad got an eviction notice from the owner.
Because he wanted to kick my dad out and knock down the whole block and build luxury condos. This was a
few years ago. So I remember my dad at the time was seventy and I said, "You know, Dad, what do you want to do?
"Like you have, like ninety employees, and like they're all in their 40s and 50s. You
know, they don't speak English. They're kind of, very hard to employ. Like what's going to happen to
them?" And I remember at the time my dad said, "You know, you know I'm seventy years
old. I'm too old for this." You know, "I'm too old to fight."
And I understand when my dad says that. But at the time I decided that
I wasn't too old to fight.
So, I organized the community. And. Sorry.
I organized the community and led this grass roots movement to fight city hall,
and fight one of the largest developers in all of Boston to try to hold ground.
[cheers, clapping] And at our first public hearing, it was a really amazing turnout. And we got enough press
that even the mayor changed his tune and started supporting where we were coming from. It was an incredible thing,
so after the first initial hearing, I remember going to the store afterwards
and immediately when I walked in there were these two older women who were my dad's employees, and they came, they rushed
right up to me and said, "thank you so much for what you did last night! You know, we normally don't think that we
have a voice, and we normally don't think we can advocate for ourselves in that kind of way. So thank you
for doing what you did."
did." And when I looked into their eyes I think I felt like the
same feeling probably that my dad felt when he saw the boy that once shoplifted or
saw the old women outside the store weeping. And when I looked into their eyes I saw
so
much compassion, and humility, and
grace. And it was at that moment that I understood the wisdom that my father had
given me. Thank you.
(applause)
[applause continues]
thank.